[Music]
France
home of Babar the lovable elephant who
becomes less lovable when you remember
that in the books he married his cousin
that's right your childhood elephant
hero was a cousin
the point is next Sunday France holds
the first round of its presidential
election and if you're thinking well why
should I care about that the truth is it
is way more important than you might
realize it's a very important election
what's going to happen in front of it
the future of Europe basically
overwhelmingly Frances the election that
matters but these French elections take
place at the crossroad of European
history it's really defining Europe's
fate
that's right the fate of your breasts in
the hands of a country that looks at
snails and says I have got to get you in
my mouth but it is not an exaggeration
to say that post brexit and with a wave
of far-right populism sweeping Europe
the fate of the EU may hang on this
election multiple candidates support a
French brexit and the consequences of
that would be steep and frankly it's not
bragging that your French is out of the
EU is the end of the EU and the end of
the eurozone so a lot of things we get
they're not the result of the French
elections it's true this could be the
most disastrous French exit in history
and that is acknowledging that a French
exit normally refers to drinking an
entire bottle of red wine and then
leaving the party with the hosts wife so
so this is a critical election or
technically to critical elections the
election takes place in two rounds one
on April the 23rd the next on May the
7th the first round will see all the
candidates complete the votes in the
second achieving nobody got more than
half the votes in the first round the
top two contenders will face off what a
ridiculous system
well the 51 individual contest and a lot
points based on outdated demographic
data that can result in a decisive loser
in the popular vote count somehow
winning that's just stupid
growing your brawn they're still working
out the kids and their democracy this
collection comes at a time of great
volatility France has suffered a string
of major terror attacks their
unemployment rate is hovering around 10
percent and their current president
Francois Hollande isn't even running for
a pretty good reason the latest opinion
polls have come out Francois Hollande is
at an all-time low
I mean even got close to zero we get
ready for it according to this poll only
four percent of French people are
satisfied by francois or noms presidency
four percent all percent to put that in
perspective
apparently the very lowest album school
in Metacritic history is 15 percent that
Kevin Federline's playing with fire an
album about which billboard raved in
general Federline enunciates well but
even without alarms running his
Socialist Party is divided and
struggling with one early contender to
replace him Manuel Valls so widely
disliked that this happened yahoo know
it happened an hour ago in this cafe
behind me cafe boy well-known to spaz
berg residence a man approached Manuel
Valls and threw flour at him look
anywhere else it might be a bad sign to
have flour thrown at you but in a
country where pastries have greater
constitutional rights and people it is
technically possible that that was
actually an honor so who is running for
this important job well well there are
actually 11 candidates at the moment and
we'll get to the main ones in a minute
but first you're going to want to meet
some of the outsiders there is Jacques
Chaminade a conspiracy theorist who once
said that the Queen of England was
involved in international drug
trafficking and whose platform includes
a plan to colonize Mars which he
explained magnificently Raja napadas
reported airspace trendy user object
below convey a loser a Star Wars awesome
a so Star Wars a reckless pace dosa
now if they were girls and I found out
here people you're right
he just said Larry Skywalker and that
weird bear presumably meaning to Baca I
really think that should have been those
characters names instead hi I'm Han Solo
this is Larry and this is our friend
that weird bear or whatever the is
I don't know then there is no laugh at
who as you can see is almost effectively
French he once went on a 39 day hunger
strike to protest a threat to jobs to
his constituency and his campaign ads
are mesmerizing he wrote on a train in
lieu D black and white works on his farm
dances around and then mows a hillside
shirtless his entire life seems like an
attempt to win the game show called so
you think you can fry the thing is that
there are currently four main candidates
with a real shot at getting to the
second round
there is Francois Fiat the former French
Prime Minister now he was once the
leading candidate but has since fallen
back in the polls thanks to Penelope
gate which sounds like a scandal
involving selling weapons-grade uranium
to Penelope Cruz but but it actually
involves fear allegedly paying his wife
Penelope and children hundreds of
thousands of euros of public money for
little or no work and the accusations
don't stop there there are reports he
may have breached electoral rules after
receiving a donation of two suits that
together cost thirteen thousand euros I
am perfectly allowed to be given a suit
by a friend it's not against the law
oh you're right that is a completely
normal thing for adult friends to do
happy birthday friend I've got you two
suits that cost about seven thousand
dollars each because that is a non
suspicious amount to spend on a gift for
a friend
how not weird is this couldn't be not
weird or right so the French public
turned on fear and you will never guess
how they express their anger moments
before he took the stage at a rally
you'll see he was hit in the face with
some flour
the images of that happening right there
now apparently he had a spare suit
luckily for him oh no doesn't look great
but without a brand-new suit when you've
been essentially accused of having been
bribed in the suits ready to go for a
t-shirt and shorts there now next there
is far left candidate jean-luc mélenchon
who is anti-eu and pro hi-tech campaign
wizardry answering the eternal question
of how to be in two places at once
presidential candidates on commercial
has embraced Holograms
where am I in the Old MacDonald and now
in Paris
[Music]
cool boat very lame and very costly it
was finding out your uncle's detachable
thumb trick cost him four hundred
thousand dollars and that brings us to
the two current frontrunner and first
let's deal with Emmanuel macron poll
suggests that he is the favorite to win
the presidency which is actually
impressive considering he's never held
elected office before he is a former
banker who served as an economic adviser
to along and if you are falling asleep
just listening to me describe him you're
not alone mr. McRoy who is neither left
nor right and is generally inoffensive
to the entire population is not super
attractive to anyone ouch he is
generally inoffensive and not super
attractive to anyone that makes him
sound like he's the guy who played the
main character on How I Met Your Mother
this man and this is true has no name
MacGraw as a centrist policy that is
pro-business pro-europe and aimed at
boosting Frances economy but the most
interesting thing about him might be
this Immanuel Michael Wood was a
small-town boy from amia who met his
future wife here at school the only
twist is that she was his teacher it's
true he married his Prince Peter who is
20 years older than him and as a result
macron a 39 year old man now has seven
step grandchildren and I'm sorry but a
man in his thirties suddenly ending up
with seven step grandchildren self at
the plot of a direct-to-dvd Ashton
Kutcher movie called
even on a nine-hour flight this movie is
unwatchable and by the way if you're
wondering did macron get any baking
ingredient thrown at him during the
campaign well what do you think
MMN we're macron just got hit in the
head with an egg so Teresa study two
cups of flour and now I'm eggs now I
don't know if the French people are any
closer to picking a president but
they're about halfway to making a decent
crepe and that leaves us with marine
lepen microns biggest challenge and
honestly she is the main reason you
should be invested in this election the
lepen name carries a lot of baggage in
France her father was John marine lepen
who co-founded her party the National
Front and he is a deeply unpleasant
human being
Joe Murray lepen famously dismissed the
Nazi gas chambers as a mere detail of
history the courts have repeatedly found
him guilty of questioning the Holocaust
oh that's just a taster he also said of
one Jewish critic will put a batch in
the oven next time which is the kind of
vile horrific anti-semitism that gets
most people permanently banished from
society as well as an Oscar nomination
for directing hacks Aldridge now now
marine lepen actually kicked her father
out of the party and has worked very
hard to rehabilitate the National Front
reputation and present a softer image
and to listen to one French voter it
seems to have worked
okay homeward Afeni why vote for
national it's simple it's marine lepen
if it were her father in charge it would
be no because he's a crazy old man back
then there were skinheads fascists in
the past with marinas not like that at
all there's an elegance a bit of
restraint yeah but elegant presentation
does not negate poisonous content a
Klansman is still a Klansman even if you
slap a monocle and a top hat on him and
give him the cane wait wait hang on hang
on
take off that sheet I'm Lee not
your
the voice is pointing the pen is
particularly popular among young people
in France who have a a high rate of
unemployment and I've responded to our
promises to institute programs to give
them jobs and encourage a national
preference in employment making it more
expensive for businesses to hire
non-citizens but beneath her a slick
presentation the Pens message is vicious
a few years back he was asked about
immigrants in France and while her
answer started well it quickly
deteriorated mr. Nottoli art USP 10-year
rule a druman éstos language except oh
ye dusk and estan en sus oídos capita no
Jews except on a par no a coda so
questions yep a cheetah a cur men posit
a local developer to say a kyboot
illiterate farm hold on brutalizing your
weapon stealing your wallet again that's
just boilerplate racism but people are
coming to take my wallpaper it's
something a crazy person says no one
wants your wallpaper you catastrophic ly
weird person and what Francie is a
proudly secular society some of the pens
proposals would take that to the extreme
should Muslim people be allowed to wear
head scarves no more poor dunno I'm
opposed to wearing headscarves in public
places
that's not France it's not just head
scarves lepen says she would ban
yarmulkes in public any conspicuous
symbol of religious belief
what a cheek personal out to be wear a
turban no no not in public
no we don't have a lot of Sikhs and Rams
we've got some but we don't really hear
much from them or about them which is
good news is it is it only such a
reprehensible thing to say about people
you hope to govern that and I never
thought I'd say this to someone because
it doesn't really make sense
I hope someone steals your wallpaper I
don't know why they would Marines but uh
okay
so 2-0 so whatever the result of this
election lepen has already dangerously
normalized the National Front winning
seats at the local level and even a few
in the legislature and one of the
frustrating things about watching this
unfold from America is this feels a
little like deja vu a potentially
destabilizing populist campaigning on
anti-immigrant rhetoric who rages
against the elites despite having a
powerful father and inherited wealth
even as all the experts reassure us that
there is no way that this can possibly
happen but this is she's not going to
win because in the second round
everybody will unite against her I would
think that most people it doesn't matter
which political caller will vote for my
contest to block the way to marine lepen
she will not me
we will not have in France another Trump
election she is not named Donald Abed
she's just marina Levin she will not be
returned that is the kind of reckless
overconfidence you normally only see in
a period piece movie about a tragedy
right the Hindenburg is the safest form
of travel there is I'd like to see
static electricity even try to set
bishop on fire I tells ya but I would
not be so confident especially because
while turnout in French presidential
elections is normally around 80 percent
this time whole shoulder around a third
of French voters might choose to abstain
and if they do that in the second round
the pens very motivating voters could
put her in office and that could be bad
for a lot of people so please France I
would like to try and convince you not
to sit this election outter to do that
let me appeal to your innate French
sense of superiority over the US and
Britain which is and it pains me to
admit this not entirely misplaced real
French quasi are buttery pillows of
perfection whereas the American cross
sandwich is an ungodly abomination
yet your French wines are magnificent
certainly superior to British wines
which takes like Michael Caine urinated
in some grave to you in France love
nothing more than acting like you are
better than Britain and America well now
is your chance to prove that because we
made populous nativist choices with
brexit and Trump and to be honest it's
not working out so great for us so far
and now you have a populist nativist
choice of your own and just imagine how
superior you can feel if you don't make
the same mistake that we did I really
want to convince you more but I know you
don't like big gaudy gestures so allow
me to convince you in the elegant
restrained manner that you prefer please
please please join me France and a cozy
be fun
[Applause]
never to throw another free wine for you
music and smoke into each other's faces
yes
dongjun inicio de calais emetic Angela
Republic process ojos de Condillac
written each process Kayla Hassan
lzb Paulo process men see Jessica
Montano baka belong
Rosanna in we make damn elephant
we wish let people play a couch a more
normative Elliott as Nene of fukube
Norfolk apparently mahi-mahi brain komen
do Hosea included could demagogue Moscow
old Jew dokku demagogue Hoobler mucosa
say see a vodka so take o Allah o turtle
appeal no Sepideh Libya Oman Oman
Gontier
ecology day open surah liberté égalité a
Eternity vault ensemble calm the
Larry Skywalker cool what photographers
do EV not pursue less wine
we focus while Alison m41 me
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
where did you disappear
[Applause]